this gentleman and his lady Val baby
girls weak weak here she's in the green
room no issue she is she's nine days old
we brought took an uber here herself
very fixed baby yeah one star she gave
the driver for not jingling the keys he
was using it
yeah I'm glad you guys are excited a lot
of people I was talking about on stage I
do stand up and I was saying we just had
a baby and somebody unprovoked and the
audience just went your life is over
yeah you know what I say to that
what good I'm done with this 39
uninterrupted seasons of this yeah time
to bring in somebody new do you
understand you're ready to transfer on
regulated man just doing whatever I want
oh geez we don't need any more of this
and now you here you are you're the now
now you're the now you're the Pete
Holmes who's a dad I'm a dad now it's
crazy it is crazy especially I mean I've
known you for a bunch of years and I
think of you as this perpetually this
this guy who's always gonna be sort of a
youthful kid like and now now you're
responsible for another human life I am
yeah
and you know what it's no big deal well
wait a minute you're like five days into
this I'm gonna tell everybody relax
yeah I'm an expert it's not what what I
mean is everybody's trying to scare you
there like it cries look out your cries
yeah I hope you don't like sleeping cuz
they're Christ yeah you're focusing on
the wrong thing it cries it's like going
up to someone eating ice cream like you
know we die one day
[Laughter]
and the miracle of life came out of my
wife yes he cries sometimes I don't mind
I waited nine months to meet her I'd
like to take a peek a boo yeah every
once in a while that's sweet
the best part of sleeping anyway I don't
mind getting up because the best part is
falling asleep that's the only part
you're there for
and I get to do that 22 times a night I
get up I feed her I change her and then
I go oh I'm slipping into the caramel
over and over that's that's how I fall
is that here's the big thing so the baby
not sleeping is your wife getting any
how's your wife doing she's doing
wonderful it was a fifty hour labor what
five five zero and then well some of you
know some of you are like is that normal
yeah it's not normal it's crazy that's
long that's a long one and I was there
she is a goddess she is badass it's the
strongest thing I've ever seen another
person do
she is Beyonce and I will worship her
the remainder of my days if she breasts
Britt you guys breastfeeding she is
breastfeeding breastfeeding that is a
big sea you know that is a big question
is not everyone does it you know some
people have difficulty is that going
well well we are supplementing we have
because she had a little John D's yeah
no John D's scare so we got a few little
nickname for John de Johnny's that's
just jaundice the old John D's like take
it one thing at a time yeah something a
silly nickname gonna be fun what do you
call tuberculosis rookies he's gone now
you got to make sure she's feeding yeah
that's the thing and everybody wants to
know when was the baby's last feed
that's how you say it did she have her
feed yeah
the pediatrician comes in when was the
baby's last feed like we're giving her
breast milk not tossing her a live
chicken
come out of the crib covered in blood
and feathers like oh she had her but I
was in I was in the room for the
delivery and I highly recommend it I
thought we were done with that debate
but apparently some men are still there
was a guy in the waiting room I saw that
was like you know mine was about to go
there was lady stuff and he was watching
the Cowboys game in that waiting room he
wasn't involved in any way like Don
Draper he brought a bottle of scotch and
he was watching the Cowboys game I
didn't know we were doing that get in
there get in there that's not lady stuff
that's the most badass thing you can do
we looked like gladiators there was
blood and sweat and tears and yelling
and you're gonna be in the waiting room
watching men pretend fight over a ball
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you